christine villemin la mère du petit
grégory inculpée de l'assassinât de son
fils par le juge d'instruction elle a
été immédiatement écroué
réunion de masse du comité directeur du
parti socialiste après la polémique
jospin fabius pierre mauroy estime
aujourd'hui qu'il faut donner la
priorité au parc
connor ceux sortis de wimbledon par son
compatriote que rennes une demi finale
qui s'est jouée contre l'équipe
mesdames messieurs bonsoir l'information
est tombée dans la soirée c'est le tout
dernier rebondissement il est de taille
dans la sphère de la mort du petit
grégory puisque sa mère christine
villemin a été inculpé tout à l'heure de
l'assassinât de son fils par le juge
d'instruction elle a été immédiatement
écroué
une information qui n'est pas tout à
fait une surprise en savait que le
magistrat s'était fait sa conviction et
non pensait qu'il soupçonnait la mère de
l'enfant mais c'est donc maintenant
officiel
reste à savoir quelles sont les raisons
l'épreuve où les présomptions qui l'ont
amené à prendre ses décisions sur place
marcel trillât encadrés par les
commissaires andrieu ego razzie de la
police judiciaire de nancy et leurs
hommes feyssine villemin était encore
sans emphase lorsqu'elle s'est présentée
devant le juge lambert au palais de
justice d'epinal il était 16h30
deux heures plus tard elle était inculpé
d'homicide volontaire sur la personne de
son fils grégory et écroué à la prison
de metz inculpés et non pas coupable
il n'est pas superflu de le rappeler
dans cette affaire si fertile en coups
de théâtre et en accusation sans preuve
or les preuves manquent toujours le jeu
lambert ne dispose pour l'instant que
d'une troublante convergence de
présomptions la contre expertise
graphologique déposé ce matin sur son
bureau et qui confirmerait les
ressemblances frappantes ancône
l'écriture de christine villemin est
celle du corbeau mais d'autres
graphologue avait accusé bernard laroche
votre expertise déposée ce matin celle
des chimistes qui aurait établi une
ressemblance frappante entre les
cordelettes retrouver chez les villemin
et les liens qui ligotaient le petit
grégory et puis il ya les incertitudes
de l'emploi du temps de christine
villemin
à l'heure du crime et les témoins qu'il
aurait vu poster une lettre à l'heure où
le corbeau expédié la sienne les
présomptions des suspicions mais encore
une fois aucune preuve formelle il faut
donc espérer cette fois que la justice
pourra suivre son cours sereinement et
que chacun se gardera de toutes
conclusions trop hâtives